I was 13 years old just letting you know
now that is the least crazy part of this
story 13 for me was not your typical 13
I was living at my grandma's house at
the time and my grandma was a flight
attendant so she would always be out of
the country and I have aunts and uncles
that are close in age with me my uncle
was throw in this house party all these
people are 16 17 years old and it was
rage and hos pop and everyone was
enjoying themselves his buddy
forgot his car at a Taco Bell down the
street he didn't want to leave he told
his girlfriend to go get his car she
don't want to go alone cuz I was the
young guy they're gonna make me do
everything they don't want it so they're
like oh with my girlfriend get my car
and bring it back we're walking down the
street she's older she's cool when
you're younger you said you tend to
think anyone that's older than you is
automatically way cooler than you the
idea started occur to me like wow this
girl is so beautiful I just wanted to
kiss if I got a kiss I would be the
belle of the ball or and the coolest guy
in my middle school I would say we get
to the car there's nobody there it's
like the middle of the night it's the
only car in the lot just complaining
about her boyfriend I stopped her and I
was like I'm gonna do this
I remember saying something about like
you know you deserve better girl and I
went in for a kiss probably maybe
kissing one person before but as we're
kissing she just took it to a whole
other level there was tongue then
there's all these other things and I'm
like what is going on one thing leads to
another and I end up losing my virginity
in a Taco Bell parking lot
it was the most beautiful moment I've
ever shared in a Taco Bell I was just
thinking whoa this is what it feels like
this is what all those like LimeWire
download videos were I was like I'm
officially a man so we're finished so
she just drives me back like a chauffeur
because I'm still putting my pants on in
the backseat right when we get to the
party she just like darts off away from
me of me I feel like a million bucks
I'm telling everybody I'm not even
thinking about the boyfriend I'm going
every room saying like yeah you know it
was amazing of dope just like in this
drunken confident days of manliness the
boyfriend pops behind me he's like it in
the kitchen we got to talk
holy [ __ ] I'm gonna get my ass kicked
these guys are older than me taller than
me stronger than me so he looks at me is
thank you uh you got sex with my
girlfriend and I'm like yeah I did he's
like okay yes what's up bro that's what
he came out to me like give me a high
five my uncle's laughing he's laughing
I'm sort of giggling cuz I still think I
might get my ass whooped but he in a
very gross way was very supportive of my
first time why do you think he was so
supportive and didn't kick your ass
these weren't the best people in general
who would even put a thirteen-year-old
in that situation is beyond me she had
enough hearing about how I guess her
boyfriend is okay with it and that's
what pissed her off so she ended up
leaving the party and honestly I don't
think I've ever seen her again so it
sounded like she did it to get back at
her boyfriend I got caught in a very
dysfunctional relationship and a sexual
love triangle luckily I moved back in
with
mom and being the forceful Catholic
woman she was my sex life had a halt
funny how like a 13 year old I
officially started my dry spell and then
it didn't happen again till I was 18
with like a high school girlfriend how
at that time differ from gonna talk
about parking lot you know it was sweet
and nice but I was like man that it was
pretty boring it's like where's the
nearest Taco Bell in order to match the
excitement I had we're having sex with
someone that I would never have a shot
with is like me now having sex with
Rihanna you try to have a normal sex
life after that there is this this term
I didn't hear later on in my life that
made so much sense is that the biggest
sex organ is your brain and unless you
got that in check it's gonna dictate
what experiences you have with that
person I mean the thing is yeah if it
happened a kid of my own I would not be
happy with it at all say at least do it
in a Tripoli parking lot I mean be
better than me at least